jules et léonie ses deux enfants sont
les héros des cahiers de vacances
éponyme créée dans les yvelines en 2019
le but les jeunes consolident leurs
acquis cette année un nouveau cahier de
ce1 vers le ce2 est sorti dans celui ci
les deux personnes font le tour du monde
ils ont un deltaplane de tap and magic
qui va leur faire faire le tour du monde
ils disent au revoir à leurs familles
leurs amis sont là et l'arrivée
appareils la famille bien les accueillir
et cette fois ci ils sont sans le
périgord on voit les gorges de la
dordogne de façon ludique avec des jeux
et des dessins du monde entier les
enfants on découvre un peu plus sur la
terre l'une des cofondatrices et
professeurs des écoles et ne trouvait
pas de cahier de vacances a conseillé
aux élèves
c'est ainsi qu'est née l'idée j'avais
vraiment dans le dans le coeur et dans
la tête de proposer à mes élèves des
cahiers de vacances en fait qu'ils
fassent grandir l'enfant dans toutes ses
dimensions qui est un bon niveau
scolaire qui est une exigence au niveau
des exercices et du contenu et puis
également que l'enfant apprenne
énormément de choses au niveau de la
culture générale au niveau du patrimoine
l'amour de son pays de l'environnement
le monde qu'il en soit en fait voilà
qu'il soit vraiment mûri les deux
fondatrices ont aussi souhaité évoquer
l'état de la planète
il voit aussi des océans qui sont plein
de déchets plein de plastique est
vraiment salée préoccupent-ils 10 mai
mais qu'est ce qu'on fait de cette
magnifique terre en plus ils ont la
chance contrairement à nous de pouvoir
du ciel avec lord hunt a plane donc
c'est vrai qu'ils sont voilà ils sont
bien sensibilisés et et voilà il
découvre vraiment là le bonheur que leur
donne en fait une ville simple 3000
exemplaires ont été vendus la première
année 6000 la deuxième pour 2021 les
deux entrepreneuses espère en vendre
autant que l'année dernière mais pour
elle le but reste la qualité des cahiers
de vacances